sólo unas semanas le bastaron a george a
sus 21 años para adaptarse al frío
canadiense y a los corredores
sobrecalentados del metro de montreal
donde pasa hasta dos horas por día que
se fragmenta como el metro como el
autobús la bicicleta también camino y
todos muy bien pero conducir un poco
en su maletín siempre lleva un libro
casi nunca en árabe su lengua materna
antes de aquí sabía un poco de francés
porque en siria había estudiado francés
me parece que leer es divertido como
leer en francés o en inglés o en otro
idioma también el español y toda la
grafía española
nuevos idiomas un nuevo mundo lejos de
qamishli donde creció junto con sus
amigos en 2015 llegó la guerra luego el
exilio con sus padres su hermana y su
hermano vivieron un mes en el líbano
antes de ser patrocinados por una
familia canadiense
al principio fue muy difícil para
nosotros sobre todo tener que irnos de
siria cuando llegamos no sabíamos muy
bien cómo hacían las cosas por como las
diligencias para el seguro médico la
tarjeta del seguro o para encontrar un
empleo y eso escasez
ahora
seis años más tarde
georgia aprendió a amar canadá y lo
demuestra es voluntario en la cruz roja
trabaja en primera línea contra la
pandemia de kobe 19
another torno es nuestro turno de
agradecerle a este país que nos acogió
implicándonos de esta manera en varias
tareas he conocido a muchas personas de
diferentes países
creo que si estuviera en síria nunca
habría soñado llegar así de lejos
regresar a siria quizás algún día george
lo ha pensado ya sea para vivir allá o
para sanar sus heridas